[Music]
[Applause]
let's now welcome nicola bonanno
6 slit google cloud italia
good morning everyone and welcome to google
cloud next milan
i'm why you didn't know me nicola
bonanno i'm the  sales manager of
the Italian division and it is a great honor for me to
have you here today
I will be the guide for you to
take by the hand during this event
in this location so beautiful
so truly full that
a location that  I heard first in the
foyer and maybe not totally new for
some of you
probably just a few days ago but I
can guarantee you that the topics that
will be treated today will be
absolutely new for you we have prepared
a really rich agenda with
really targeted topics  about
what your needs are and therefore I will tell you
with certainty that you will not regret a
second visit to
today's superstudio topics  in fact they will show how why
today to consider google
cloud for any type of
technological innovation project
today we cannot indeed you can
not allow me not to
consider google cloud and
we will show you the
investments made by this company to
remain absolutely at the top
of the  '' technological innovation
we will demonstrate how we have reorganized ourselves
in order to better meet the
needs of our customers to serve
both start-ups, the smallest
innovative companies as well as the
most consolidated companies the large
enterprises we will
demonstrate how we are absolutely
different from everyone else  our
competitors
what are our advantages what
are our differences precisely but
above all we will show you why
we believe we are absolutely
positioned to take you by the hand and lead you
in this transformation project for
the next few years
I am in google cloud since 2009 s  I
was the witness if we want of
the transformation rules of this company
but I have also noticed how in recent years
even the market has profoundly and
radically changed
this is why about a year ago
we decided to change the name
not because we particularly liked to change the
name but because  we wanted to
respond in a different way to
the needs
that customers, customers like you
asked us for and for this reason we
obviously gave more emphasis to
what our strong point is the cloud
associated with the value of the brand as
iconic as google and today google  cloud
is a complete
division within which the
infrastructural division therefore includes all the
virtual machines part storage networking
the big data analytics solutions the
collaboration messaging platform to work and
collaborate in a different way
within your company but
obviously  also all our by max
ep  lp ai for machine learning to
train a machine
learning algorithm up to obviously the
whole part of the platform the
chrome platform which according to ai di sim
by 2018 will be adopted by about
25 percent of all forces an
andrid file and  obviously also the
most popular android platform mobile platform
in the world with about 90 percent
also in Italy in its mode
its enterprise version 2017 for us
an absolutely turning point
in the last year and specifically in
the last six months we have
witnessed a
truly unprecedented growth acceleration
pearls therefore therefore a special institution moment
for this we
particularly want to be here today with
you a special moment because we have
witnessed not only an
incredible amount of projects in which we have
been involved with our
technology, however, also has the quality of these
projects
the innovativeness of these projects  tti is
also for the value of the companies that
have decided to undertake this
path with us today we can
truly boast of having in our
customer portfolio
absolutely iconic companies not only in
the Italian market in the Italian scene
but also in the international scene
as you can see companies that
come from  from any type of segment
companies of different sizes companies
with totally different histories companies
that in any case all have decided to
undertake this path of
innovation and transformation with
google cloud but today also our
partner ecosystem has
grown further we can boast about
13,000 companies that have  believed in
our business and have invested in
our technology the company that
obviously can accompany you on
this path and others within
these companies.I would like to thank in
particular some of those who are
present here today and who have helped us
so that  this event was possible
therefore I warmly invite you to
visit their stands to
touch their technologies first hand to verify their
experts are in this field you will find
them in their stand on my left but
starting towards the end I would like
above all to thank you are over
unfortunately we also had to close
the registrations with a certain advance
so thanks to your answer
surely next year we will take
the even bigger location and this
really makes me very happy it makes us
really very proud as you
also see a rage a very
representative audience of that  that the market
at the moment
for this reason we have also created
we worked to make an agenda that
was truly relevant and of value
for all of you by creating content that
could be relevant to each
of your of your segments this is
today's agenda
so  after me I will have the pleasure and
the honor of calling on the pa  lco sebastiano
in roth our vice president emea who will show
us our vision
for the cloud world in the coming years,
the event of the morning will then continue
with four presentations that will
show us how to work in
a safer way in a smarter way
by leveraging  on what
are the data work in a more
collaborative way within the company
with new new generation tools but
also work in a more open way to
create platforms that
are open and more integrable then
we will have the pleasure of having three on stage
client companies who will share with
us what their experience is and
this makes me
particularly proud
at the end towards the end of the morning
I will be there again for the greetings for
the conclusions and then the day will
continue with the vertical breakout in the
afternoon this point to me  all that remains is
to wish you a good day and
thank you again and give  and welcome
to sebha sia and marotta
thanks a lot thanks a lot thanks to
nicolai good morning english and with
friends different ha mai né miss fashion
by light di bachi milan
lui li by light and business racing
italy has been working for business
value at google cloud connect fast
business google google plus campani
mission one man show with music
diaz bank nations campani will
mind a mendes il living with this is armena
assets business di sguardi approve
into the wild in addition to being
manages village nord e da we hope
providing the best skele open graph
investment  in there frears amin sismica
minima mainstream and webank london
fashion week end in this club claudio
garzelli believe that it's five anywhere
anytime inside the power of cloud
the power the place we live for everyone
power individuals en place and in
vicinita professional golf and nights
in chi  i film manager di schonach lei
all we believe that we can
matic the input the way we are the world
investmen  t and many of you and i due le
ong evil investing in opening new
regency will challenge the asphyxiated leaf meter
and jingle picture print now r idee
biljana awards in france
you know da said to have hands four by
two million years on every day service
for love  you man il barolo destroy
ring the shining analytics da rising sun
of business and infrastructure di scampi
con 51 vadis maze in game
google clowns poche mango the hub
exceeded di business one
eni backstage expectation lifting
barizza if you e explores cloud services
holdings casting restyling snap
application  fascinating everyday systems
da ring of feelings phasing out and gis
use by using her on train il club
weeklynews tinga tinga if you're the
hope and sometimes wise cloud partner
sky section
housing and genes and see what can we
build new vision marketplace single
based on  the cloud builder analytics del
west end by google analytics campanella
chiesti 30 jun stop della studios
fifteen bates and the a team  manager of
shaun white bright eyes and david
function in flux campli sax of da rising
dei rusties arouse long time and
complexity competition however it follows
expansive mary mary king harry business
sale light magic of weapons jing liu jo
stare light imaging business state
lighting match on the floor  di forza you
don't know out by French france cloud
cloud cleaning information week end of
life monsters
luigi suite di office for big thing by
[Music]
shaun by us from books getting this is
by four mosche news and will be using
compliance piano a  tenca cloud to defend
the last user partners nicola wiki
space ship sp tel
five languages some flops in short the syste
two years from next gen appli
ation and providing technology desig
fashion city am beginning of rome ends
n bing google france unit jacks
n bush in languages smokey eyes  a
this king draft level guide
contain session it's so easy to bill
deployed stations cross all the wave on
any kind of vice into the plu  ck lo son
sensors gesture club di via binda want
that share this day will be the time
has the right after il medico in fintech
manifacturing ben d'energia mec energy
and media campani ai team di sisb clouds
and bass clear and bess technology
business is  business
mercy mercy sebastien thanks to everyone
and a warm welcome from me too i
am gabriele and today with me on stage
there is mattia poretti we are part of
the pre-sales engineering team mattia
will be with me because obviously in the
next sessions we will also do
some demos  I saw that the speakers who
preceded me mentioned the
time they spent in google so
mattia let's continue the tradition and
remember that both you and me both you and me
this week we celebrate an
anniversary our eleven years 11
years in google
we started together  then we are
talking about years so let's talk about
how much time google has invested in
this in creating this infrastructure
is from 15 to  nni that he has a strong
investment of about 30 billion
dollars
employing more than 20 thousand engineers with
the aim of making it
easier and safer to run
software on a
world-scale platform and with an evident quality you
will surely recognize the products
listed in this  sly also presented them
sebastien previously each
of these products is used by more
than a billion users and for sure among
this billion users there are
some products you
have used them and you too are
witnesses of the quality that this
network  this infrastructure offers
this type of applications but
clearly there are seven missing one
the eighth product which is
our gcp because your applications
the applications of our customers
running on the platform reach more
than a billion shoots of users
many developers  many companies small
companies medium companies large companies
have de  ciso to innovate on
this on this infrastructure for
many reasons among which there are a
scalability never seen before remembered by
sebastien and the p in the example of pokémon
go a full reliability an extreme
security
and it is precisely on this that we will base ourselves
but first  to get to security
which are
four pillars that guide
the engineering of google in developing
this platform you can see them in
this slide therefore the security that is
the basis of the reputation that a network
that a company creates in the network and therefore
the basis of  trust that your
customers will place in you in your
services and in your applications
the second is intelligence the computer
refine the intellectual abilities of
man
this infrastructure offers
solutions that allow you to
reach limits that were unthinkable until
a few years ago  and therefore I am at your
disposal to exploit them the third is
the collaborative part the computers have
c  the modality in which
we work has changed
let's read inform ourselves we play we have fun and they have
led us from an
individual collaboration to a group collaboration
that has considerably changed the way
we work in our companies to
end up on the opening part opening
means free software to the pious and
open available and means putting
means basically three things to
put in your hands the control
of the computing and therefore the control of the
business
according to giving you the possibility to
move the
software you are already using in such an infrastructure the
programs the applications you are already
using in yours  data center and
allows you to move to
other operators if necessary, then if it
becomes necessary let's start with
security and I begin by saying that until a
few years ago security we
recognize we recognize it was a
brake on the adoption of public cloud services
this  has changed because  to
date, security is the
main reason in our opinion to adopt
public cloud services
google says yes but not only google says it
for example garner in February
released security cloud ripor in
which he clearly states that
public cloud infrastructures are to
be clearly considered  more secure than
any implementation
and another fundamental message is that
using the google cloud platform you
access the same levels of
security as google of its
internal applications and its
business applications not a
similar infrastructure the same your
data your applications run
as they run
applications google applications
since the beginning since 15 years ago
google had the problem of offering
services in an open environment so
it could not apply the
classic security concepts related to the perimeter
because all users were
outside the perimeter we are
speaking of apply  Clearly web
based actions
therefore had to develop a
multi-level security layer in
depth on each component of the
system we sell listed here from
right to left starting from the right
the hardware part up to the
left the protection
of the network users has already spoken
sebastian therefore the  investments and
because a network and encrypts all data
in transit both from you to a data center
but also between data centers is very
important for your
safety and security of your data and
clearly we cannot cover all
these levels and there is  it is a session I
would have no cause dedicated to this afternoon
in which we will go to all
these levels so in this
very short session we focus on someone
and we start for example from the physical
security sebastien spoke of 750
security engineers obviously but there are
also many other people  who
collaborate on the protection of this
infrastructure here  ndi for example we have
mentioned the seacure.it guards the guards
who protect our data centers
in the photo there is the example of the
hamina data center in finland
but there are a lot of people who
work on certifications
and
in compliance with international regulations
remember the situation
of the gdp know if we go to the hardware part instead
an interesting innovation in
terms of security made by google is the
tip ton processor one of the basic principles
on this is that google does not trust
any component of the system so
let's take for example if a
virtual machine must go to read a data
on cloud storage absolutely this
communication even if it occurs in a
google data center is considered
insecure
so every component that is now a
hardware component or a
software component must have an identity must
have a certificate must authenticate
before carrying out an action and that is
why on all our components
is ins  tall this small
titans processor that contains
the identities and certificates that
are used at every attempt to
connect with another component
of the platform by encrypting the
communication even if for example two
components are in the same wool or
even if they are physically connected
in the slide  as an example we have
in this case a network card so it
is also installed simply in
a network card
let's jump to the top of the
dose stack and talk about
user
protection customers who rely on our
infrastructure report that the  last
bastion of security that remains to
protect the user the user who is the
subject of different types of
phishing attacks password theft
there are also malicious users etc.
one of the innovations that google has made
is to invest
in two-factor authentication
being  one of the founders of the custody
alliance is one of the major cont  rebutors
this mode is not based on one
time passwords on access time codes
that are easily
hb there sorry for the English but is based on
a certificate that installed on the
key that allows us to
authenticate with two factors therefore with
something we know and  with something
we own in google each
employee
uses this protection system and
is considered one of the
most advanced mechanisms to fight the deficit today
we come to tools instead of
google puts in your hands to
manage the security of your data there
are many of these  tools in
this who notes we have chosen to
tell you about data loss prevention and
ai which was originally available
on the gmail infrastructure for a long time
but has now been brought has been
extracted from gmail engine of alps and is
available as a service for all
applications of  google and for all the
applications you want to
build it is m  very important because it
allows you to make security in the context and
therefore contextualize the data and then
apply appropriate policies and all
this is done automatically
thanks to these plans and it is precisely
on this point on this point that with mattia
we will try to show you in practice how to
exploit this  functionality
with a quick demo thanks gabriele as
gabriele leather rightly says now it
is to show you these technologies in action for a moment
in particular let
's see the last of which gabriele told us that
precisely data loss prevention in the plans
a technology used
internally in google but  even in many
of our products to make sure that
there are no
unwanted data losses what you see here a chat
nothing new indeed technology
enough 2000s probably the
peculiarity is that a chat thing that
happens more and more often used
within  a contact center ie
I typically go on  line I have to talk to
a company and the pop up appears that
tells me you want to talk to someone in this
case I am this theoretical hypothetical
chat operator
who is talking to alice in this
exchange of information as you can see
alice asks me about things and me  he puts
personal information which is
his name obviously on the phone number she
is an American customer so
the social security number could
be our social security number and other
information
I then maybe I could also interact
add other information as in
this case I ask him if his
credit card and I simply come
to the chat as often happens precisely
these interactions
if you have this on the phone
ask you for attention because it could
be registered for this purpose for
this other purpose the problem of
recording and storing this
information that as you can see there is a
lot of information  which
often cannot be stored in the
systems  i in themselves and my business
and this type of technology
comes to meet us because you can see by clicking
and chat
so before transferring this data
to a specific and
stable place
what this application does
using them from al ppi manages to
highlight all this information
sensitive as the name in this case the
telephone number
the social security number even
manages to highlight the same
information within the
image that had gone there
so it even manages to cover
masking this information
within an image and obviously
also  the credit card we have
seen here did this so we could
take this information for
internal analysis as we best believe for
our to our business needs
in addition even if not strictly
related to the di alpi ep ivy I do see
that there is a  other ip ai which is called
instead natural language processing adp
which allows something  Another very
interesting one in this use case which is
the ability to understand the text that is
what is inside in this chat
succeeds therefore allows you to understand the
semantics of what happened
within this chat and eddie
manages to  extract as you see the
topics the entity
within this chat and even to
make an
analysis to the point of sentiment
analysis by seeing how the
theoretical trend of satisfaction both of the
customer and of the people goes, here there has been
some  probably some problem
I answered but not in the most suitable way and
matias and citro massimo in the situation
of having to acquire images
for example an application that could
be on a di arpino there were in the case,
for example, of an insurance that
acquires linked images  to a claim
how we can manage the
personal information that is in this image
absolutely if not to the pious it is
also very easy to integrate the same and pii to the
interior  or an application video
video photographic example you see
this application where he simply
takes a photograph from my laptop
maybe I should always in the context of
this interaction with a friend
I should identify
myself by showing my face and maybe also showing
my credit card  as you can see in
this case what happens is that by
taking this photograph I send this
image to our and pious and as you see
essentially nothing happens here
nothing happens because
obviously this credit card is not
true what does it mean that this number
you see  here he essentially fails
to recognize it and understand that it is not a
zero number of credit cards
yes now I try to do exactly the
same thing with one with a number that
is instead of a credit card
obviously do not write it down because it simply does not take you
very far
compared to the credit card algorithm
you should see that it is able to recognize  obscure
the number itself
according to this is the demo effect the
perfect classic perfect at the first and
we caught the question that as
you see here essentially do it
the last time there are several
pre-packaged indicators also for
different states so what do I know
about it  credit social security number there
are several things that can be
used extracted for example also here
for example the face now we are just
a little luckier because the light here
is not the best
ok now it worked and you see I had
also clicked the face and so it
removed  even my own face
then this case the recognition
of the credit card the recognition
of a face that wii switch back to
life also for the magi then
final message to close this small
segment linked to security by operating
on the gcp infrastructure and
then choosing to  innovating on our
infrastructure you have access to this
multilive security  llo which is managed
by the operator and therefore you can take advantage of
all this series of innovations in
terms of security developed by the
google security operation center and the
second second message that I ask you
to believe from this from this short
segment and that security must  to be
considered today no longer a brake on
innovation because your
developers obviously no longer have to
deal with going to protect
the infrastructure that supports your
application but instead becomes an e in the
innovation because your
developers focus instead on
solve business problems to
bring innovation to your business to
bring new ideas
and precisely on this issue so what
are the tools you have to be able
to innovate I pass the word to the
next speaker I call
our colleague paolo spreafico on stage thanks to
everyone
ok  thanks gabriele welcome to everyone
also from me with me on stage there is
andrea  that will help us with a couple of
demos to explore the
intelligence part in the part in which we are going
to demonstrate with a series of solutions
how it is possible to extract value and
be intelligence from the data that are
managed by the application within
the google cloud.
less elderly than gabriele
mattia i have been in google for eight years
andrea that from two here together
we too get to 10 so give us
credit anyway from this point of
view
the data is the fuel the data is the
fuel and of the applications of the
application without  good
data management would be of little use
and google from this point of view
be highly a guga a data
driven company for several years that we
release on the market in the form of
projects on the open source community
or in the form of white papers treated
as mapreduce has even  back in
more recently penseur flow for
the machine learning part we have this
because why  in our history
we have had to develop a whole
series of technologies and the ability to
execute them through our cloud which
has allowed us to formulate analyzes
that allow us to make
accurate decisions and lead the business
in the right
direction all obviously at the scale of google
rim a gabriele mentioned the applications the
seven applications that manage more than
a billion users
you can imagine that the amount of data
that google can analyze
daily is very vast and therefore
we had to think about something
extremely extremely scalable
kraus pander
what is klaus  pan ner klaus pan ner is the
first transactional and
relational database that scales horizontally
like a sequel database
this because because we think it is very
important to give the
developer the appropriate option to delegate to
the dbms engine the ability to manage
transactions without losing the
capacity and the  leanness of
scalability or  izontal of
applications in a sequel klaus
partner became general ieee ball in May
of this year and you can already use
within the platform to create
to pay to your
partner cloud applications and uses sequels use
the state style ensure 2011 which
is a  'excellent semantics to precisely
make the transactional stratification
maps also to make your data
coherent and scalable in the face of
geographical distribution
one of the very very beautiful things that
chaos pander provides our customers
is the automatic synchronous replication on
a geographical basis and this is possible  creating
a klaus partner instance on hundreds of
nodes distributed within the
google cloud platform is to have the guarantee
of data consistency so if
an update occurs a change a
cancellation of a data hosted in a
node on a European region or the
guarantee  that the data is
replicated instantly and consistently
within d  i the whole cluster of the
database scanner has been used for many years
within google is currently
used by more than a hundred by more than 100
applications within google it is
absolutely a system so if
you have been think that one
of google's core business systems  that google adwords
uses spammer as a database engine
to manage our customers' data that
said we see the nation disappear
so I pass the word to andrea who will
show you how it is possible to create
an application through spammer that
manages events on a global scale
so absolutely must  be
the scalable application
but it must do it in a transactional way
precisely because it is an application that
manages the sale of tickets none of
you, I imagine
in your situation, had bought a
ticket in Milan that has already been perhaps
sold on the other side of the world
here  let's see how spammer also manages
these aspects
thanks andalo good morning to all
from me too  we have just heard of
this new database recently
released by google that combines the
best of the sequel world with the best of
the no sequel world.First I would like to
show you how simple it is to create a
database with spammers
we think about how difficult it is to do it at
home we have to think about managing
the  snap shot backup consistency
think about failover replication and
so on with spender create a
database in three different regions of the world
or simply in europe as I will do
now with 10 nodes
is an operation that requires as you can
see exactly a few clicks
here is ours  database instance is
created because we created it because
we have prepared a
demo application to show you the potential of the
service which provides just as
Paul mentioned to allow you to search
for events and buy
tickets for the events themselves.
application
must be decidedly performing
we cannot allow  rci of losing
customers because a search for an event
is slow or because the purchase of a
ticket is particularly slow
and cumbersome
also we need that
worldwide there is a single inventory that
contains the availability of tickets
and rightly a ticket can be
sold  once
we see now the map showing how
the nodes of the spammer database
behind this demo application are distributed in this application
then in america in europe and asia
and right now we are managing 600
thousand ticket sales per minute
so  600 thousand transactions per minute on
a geographically distributed database
so we are guaranteeing a
deliberate service worldwide but at the
same time as we are selling
tickets
we are also guaranteeing the
transactionality of the application
thus respecting the four
acid properties that we are all used to with
classic relational databases
as the scheme of this application looks like
nothing new should be very
familiar to most of those
present in this room because it is a
typical scheme of relational databases
I invite you only to note the table
below with the tickets sold which at the
moment at 1.8 billion  record so
this database is really bearing
the bump we are simulating from about a
billion users who are simulating
this application
now let's try to run a query that
identifies all the events for which there
are still tickets available in
italy between today and tomorrow
you have seen that the execution of the query
took 337 milliseconds so
about half a second and as you see the
query is written in sql so to
use spande there is no need to
learn a new syntax a new
language to query the database and
developer developers  of
any organization can
design the scheme as they always
have  on a relational database and they
can launch those in sql this
query took about half a second
to return the results obviously
while the database is bombarded
by the impact of the traffic generated by about
a billion users while it is
simulating 600,000 it is really
carrying out 600,000 transactions per
next minute step in real life
typically applications must be
evolved mainly through two ways
first of all the modification of the schema
happens so many times that sooner or
later I will have to make changes to my
database well with spammers we can do
everything hot so we are able to
carry out  changes on the schema
continuing to guarantee the consistency
of transactions and without causing down
time of the application is also we are
also able to scale
horizontally
I wish everyone the beautiful problem
for which we are having many more
users than we expected
but we must be  able to
horizontally scale the quality
typically offered by the
sequel databases but we can also do it in spain
the database is behind
the application we are on which we are
ensuring the traffic of one
billion users at the moment to 35 nodes
distributed
worldwide now from 35  nodes I go up to 50 nodes
and here is the database scaled
horizontally from 30 35 nodes to 50 and in
a moment we are able to support
much more traffic than we might
have expected I also show you the
screen that shows that what I
am telling you the  true because
at the moment the database is entering data for
about a gigabyte for about 700 megabytes
per second as a result of the traffic we
are generating and has a size of
21.8 terabytes I
conclude by simply saying that it is
truly expanding an
exceptional product that combines the best
of  sequel world we have seen how
we are able to use if those
we have a typical scheme of the databas  and
relational and we are able to
transact because we are
selling tickets to the best of the world
non sequel I have just shown you how
I was able to
horizontally scale everything in a
highly reliable database distributed on multiple
regional level worldwide and above all
fully manager fully managed by
google so you only have to
focus on making your
application more and more beautiful and more and more
usable for your users and non-
subjects operation which is instead
managed entirely by google because
as mentioned earlier paolo spammer has been
behind many business
critical google products for many years and
I hope this can be synonymous
with performance, reliability and safety
with this sky again the word to
paolo thanks andrea
[Applause]
andrea in preparing the application
he has just shown you did not take care
of the software update infrastructure silk
is the  replication on multi rea  son are
all things that have been delegated to
the database engine he simply
had to implement the
application logic that basically underlies
the business that had to could support
a note how it was possible to
spread become a database that is scalable
on the one hand and so coherent from the point of
view  of the voting of information
two things one is the
google network the internal google network
basically allows with very very
low latency to replicate the information and
make it coherent on a
worldwide basis ensuring the availability of the
service
the global google network is entirely
managed by google so we are able
to do routing of all packets in
a self-sufficient way
on the other hand, a very
important thing that was used to
synchronize the transaction logos
used by the various spammer nodes and
the atomic clock and the time service
stamp that every single database node
manages autonomously  oma
this makes everything very efficient, it
allows you to create
a multi-region replica, having
said that once I have
basically set up
a highly available, reliable
and scalable system that manages my data,
I have to go and find forms to
use mine  data to
put together things that
allow me to extract intelligence from
this data
to do this the main service
within the google cloud platform
is called google glasses google b
query is a system that allows you
to implement a corporate data warehouse
creating an
interactive analytics system that allows you
to query terabytes of data or
petabytes of data in seconds or minutes
instead of using hours or
routers and translated query days
scale automatically does not require
any type of administration setup for
example not  I wanted to do
operations including creations of the bow spac  and / or
creation of indices are all things
delegated to the analytical engine and allows
you to stream up to 100,000
lines per second so even the feeling given back
within those can be
very efficient allowing
the implementation of real time analytics
and can be easily integrated with software
third party
a top to this we have recently
released a service to populate
those with data in a way let's
say out of the box
this service is called vicquery data
transfer service and allows very
quickly to take data that for
example comes from our world
advertising for example from adwords from
doubleclick or from youtube and popular
glasses to enable analytics
for example to understand if an
advertising campaign I'm running is
going in the right direction but as
I said glasses is an open system and the
fact that I had forever uses
sequel  has allowed a lot of
technology partners to be  employees
have commited themselves to release
solutions that are dyed that integrate
with glasses probably in
this sly you also see some of the
solutions that you may already be
using here it is important to say that the
transition to glasses is also facilitated
by this type of approach also in
Italy we have service partners
you can rely on to develop
on top queering applications
here you can see some of them
so summarizing queries as a
tool to implement a
corporate data warehouse and this is a
very typical use case that we see on the
market another  very typical use case
that we see is the shift the translation of
spark or aduc systems that require on
premise server maintenance a lot,
let's say a lot or very
painful activities from the point of view of
maintenance
I went to the cloud and therefore
we offer a service that  it's called
google cloud data proc which
basically allows you  allows you
to deplore your these
applications to a little spark
after the cloud platform also here with a
service totally managed by google
finally in the typical use case that we see
is the relative one in realtime streaming
analytics often companies begin
to do analysis of the  data batch mode
the next step is to reduce
the latency make these analyzes in
real time
maybe to create a
recommendation engine for an e-commerce site or
something like this
here pub sat our kewell
messaging engine becomes functional the purpose of
publishing  of the events and make sure
that the processing of these twenty
takes place synchronously data flow
instead represents the object that is
used to create
the data transformation pipelines the example I want to
merge a couple of data sources or
I want to go to  ordering typical data
operations etl finally glasses
in this area however remains the area
so to speak  the data warehouse in which the
data converge to make
analyzes
said that another important thing
that must absolutely be done is all
the aspect that pertains to the speech of
artificial intelligence
.
also with a view to democratizing
the approach, that is to open the approach to the
topic of artificial intelligence to as
many people as possible the publication
of quality ensor open source projects
find in this direction but also the
creation of a service manager here too
that allows you to run these
tensor algorithms  flow in
training phase in runtime at the top of
a google cloud platform and this
service is cloud machine learning engine
which is available within the
platform and new allows you to
go execute efficiently and
your algorithms intense flow on cpu or
on  gpu below a top to this already
sebastiano hinted at a whole series p
ai che  we have made it available to
take the next step as well, that
is to directly use the algorithms
trained with the knowledge based
google to go and do things like
go and
analyze images to
extract content
and here we have the pious vision that
serves the
purpose  pious neighbors and among other things they came out
a year ago in general viability and have
already paid they have already parameterized more than
a billion and a half of images so it
was a great success
we are very proud to carry on
this discourse innovations are coming
pious visions  and very
quickly they will also support
the appropriate of relying on the
google search knowledge graph or
to optimize the process of
arc is already possible but also for
documents that are darker pop
let's say so complicated but mine is more
preferred is that  that now andrea
will show you that related
to the analysis of network videos present
that the videos stan  no becoming the
most popular content on the internet only
on youtube in one minute
more than 100 hours of video are loaded
ok analyze these contents with a
technology such as the one that andrea will
show you become from and also to
optimize your business
please andrea thanks paul again for
show you the potential of
intelligent lives plus I invite you for a moment to
follow me as you try to tell me about
this video then we see a
car moving on a mountain road an
apartment a girl getting out of a
car from a taxi a dog happy maybe
for the fact  who are about to re-enter the
masters who have been with the family
presumably a birthday party
and i could still go on
what i am doing i am describing
this video exactly what
the pious intelligence videos do and i am
able to describe to you what happens
in the term the  video in fact in
particular following a single
request made to the e video intellige  nze
more for this video we are able
to actually obtain the description of
what is in the video so for
example a right car has been identified
we have all seen it
a dog has been identified in this point of the
right video and  if we went a little
further we will also see a
birthday cake so
a decidedly onerous activity that would
take a long time in reality
I can complete it with a few
seconds by calling an ep ai but the
potential of this tool
we can appreciate even more if we
put ourselves  in a condition in which
many companies may be found, i.e.
availability of many videos but a
certain difficulty in reaping the benefits
in a reasonable time so for example
I would like to create a video with the
highlights from all these
videos or I would
simply like to have them indexed
in such a way that I can search for it by
keywords and here the video
intelligences pious and are still appreciated
more we try to search in all
these videos for
everything related to baseball and
here I get three
search results in the first video baseball
appears in almost all points of the video
as we can see in the second video it
certainly appears at the beginning right in the
third video there are a couple of seconds
as we can see in which
actually there is something inherent to
the super bowls that was much searched
on google in 2016 in the united states
but let's try to do another search it's
hot we all maybe would like to be at
sea
k for the beach and here we have furth
r other
search results so a video
on barcelona with a couple of point
where the beach actually appears just
video of rio de janeiro in four
oints with 4 points where somet
ing related to the beach appears is a video
where apparently it does not seem that
the beach is very centered but there is a frame
in which there is someone who is on the
beach we can carry out  are a third
search for example looking for a dog and it is
actually the video that I
showed you at the beginning is returned
because in a certain point of that
same video there is actually a dog
as there is in two places of this
google video  photos so at the beginning it is towards the
middle so an activity that would
take many hours typically
is made usable in a few seconds in
an extremely simple way because it is
enough to invoke make a request towards
more intelligence in the video to obtain
these results
with this thank you for the  attention
I ask again for the word paolo
andrea
thanks andrea with this we have
concluded our intervention on
the intelligence part comes thanks for
the attention
I hope that our solutions have
interested it is the main message
I want to bring to me and what the
google cloud has at all  building
blocks to build a
solution that actually allows you
to extract intellig  Without your data we
avoid trying
our solutions directly on the
cloud as soon as possible thanks again and I pass the word to the
next speaker who should be
darius here he is to give the goal giani
[Applause]
boening the first good news is that
these words together with my name  I am
what remains of the exotic of this
presentation that we will do in Italian
some communications
[Applause]
there is another good news maybe yes
maybe no evaluate it evaluated by the
director tell me that we are about 20
minutes late and to draw the necessary
consequences then  I will try to proceed
as to say following the fast pace
that I hope you enjoyed in the
morning we touched on many
technologies artificial intelligence to
artificial intelligence machine
learning infrastructure security
that sees huge
investments the demo on data loss
prevention but even more if ray
say our engineering capacity on
which internal debate could  we can
tell much much more no about the
ability to develop
ever more capacious connection technologies
rather than we have seen it
ever faster and more
specialized processors
I would like to cite and show some
data our
pp for machine learning 180 teraflops
for single device up  to 11 and a
half petaflops in clusters of capacities
at your disposal of your
deep mind algorithms all the
technologies that are sure will be able to give
inspiration to your ability to innovate
and to create products and solutions that
respond to the needs
of the market and yours  and of
your companies
I hope not to be immodest
in being here on the stage to say
that in my opinion there is much more than
this and I hope you want to follow me
let's say in the presumption in the audacity
of wanting to lead by the immanence of
these technologies  to the transcendence of
what mostly I'm going to
tell you but we believe in google that
the int  the essence of innovation
lies the next in king what
leads to the emergence of those new ideas
that will form the basis the foundation
of the new generation of solutions
future lies within processes
and products with strong characteristics
enabling collaboration the ability
to work  together to achieve the
best results to achieve
the new results last year
we left for those who were in
our event atmosphere on a
reflection on the theme of modernity that
for us we had said constituted
beyond the hilarity of the most cynical I
hope  that in
the meantime
the aspiration to move a future perspective from a
present contemporaneity to a future perspective
today one year later I believe that
the theme is the contemporaneity of
the future perspective and I hope to discount the
modesty of the presumption of the audacity
to be  able to argue this
premise transcendent
the success of Jesus  eng our
collaboration product and I hope that
in the premises you were able to guess
where I wanted where I wanted to go is not
so much and not only its ability to have
been able to intercept and give a
satisfactory answer according to many of
our customers even today more
satisfactory than the solutions present
present on the market to those that were
emerging needs from new socio-
technological trends I am not going to mention them but
also and above all in its capacity to
door starting from that process that
starts from the stimulus to the proactive engagement
of people passing through the
support to a  fluid and
ergonomic interaction brings out
that humus of creativity within the company
that constitutes the foundation
of innovation innovation that is the
basis for us of that
transformation on a path of
evolution
if you want in accordance with the
media mainstream in the sense in the sense  digital
that we are looking for
surprises me a lot to  ttuality of these
issues that we have been bringing to the market for a very
long time now because because these
technologies
someone will have peeked at his aid they
are not new solutions that we have been
on the market for ten years now
the cross-section the numbers give us an
interesting cross-section the g suite this
tool  collaboration was born in
2006 as the first of its kind
totally in the cloud, today it counts on three
of the more than one billion
installations on mobile devices more than 3
million companies use it
to stimulate that
creativity process I was talking about
but  then you may wonder what the
future perspective is within this
stale contemporaneity
well the interesting thing is that
despite all this I believe we
are only at the beginning of a new
cycle of innovation that will lead us to
totally revolutionize the relationship with
a series of tools  very familiar for
ten years that accompany us
never that today meet a limit eg  they are
alien to the vast
majority of users in the ability
to draw if not the maximum much
much more and the
recovery spaces are enormous as
regards the relationship, for example with the
word process, for example the user
experience of the user with the sheet of
calculation rather than with slides
rather than in the ability to
develop on this same
platform to intercept the
workflow needs of my company
and my customers' own and to broaden
and broaden the perimeter because you will
ask are you convinced we are convinced
that we are at the dawn of  a new era of
innovation that sees
this area explode because we are able
we have already done so today we see
results for the very short refreshment of
integrating those technologies
for which we are recognized
technological market leaders who have
constituted what  it was what is
the differentiating element of our
solutions and that is  artificial
intelligence machine learning
our big data
within
collaboration solutions to solve precisely
this type of problems whose solution
I believe is essentially the
fundamental food for decrypting the
path that leads to the ability to create
new ideas that is  at the basis of the
company's ability to transform itself to
evolve to become more innovative
to be able to intercept
market opportunities better and faster to be able to
interpret in a new way if you want your business to be
more efficient and effective
but what is the catalyst for
this extraordinary action of this
extraordinary action an element
as old as the concept of entrepreneurship or, if
you want, even older than these
colleagues of ours from across the Channel, they
would say that the secret is to have
big ideas, that is, those ideas that
constitute  the foundation
of innovation
within  'company the big and dias are the
result we said of
complex creative processes within which
people express their creativity
as regards the complex processes
as far as we are concerned there are three big
elements that prevent how to say the
achievement of this  objective
the analysis shows us that essentially
the three factors are the insufficient
ergonomics of the tools in creating
connections between people
the inability to create space
within my agenda operated
by my daily life to devote to
added value activities such as those
that  concern creativity
the inability of tools to date says
it in the introduction to raise my
productivity to make available
the best of what the web and my
colleagues can offer
to solve my problems the effort
the result is evolution  of these
same products that we ourselves use
google google ship google google docs
to collaborate more  to
exploit their strong integration with the
calendar and then the chat to communicate
rather than the drive storage space
to connect people, documents and
projects, all in extreme safety, is
the result of the effort to solve
these three pros.
take a
bird's eye look at some
of the solutions to these
problems that I recall connect
people create space on the agenda
increase my
productivity we said in
the introduction artificial intelligence back beta
are a fundamental element
of the  path to achieve this to
this result increase my
productivity starting from what for
example the need to
recover access to documents already today
some of you who use google dry
will be able to see that by accessing this
tool from their mobile app they
will find  not only the classic a list of
files or folders but will already find today a
reach of a click some files this
selection the results what of the
behavior analyzed by the status
of the information to the context that I
chat within my calendar in
order to be able to propose the one that
according to the tool and according to the
behaviors and analyzed is the file that
is more likely to be
requested already today surprisingly the
analyzes tell us that 40 percent
of the content clicked is the result
of this interaction this other
example is a little more about the ability to
enable a smart job the fisher is
called is called explore  is the premise
this is the spreadsheet how to say it
was a milestone our
ability to analyze
mathematical analyzes and statistics of data
brought as to say to a wide audience but
still today the complexity
of this tool constitutes a barrier to
entry for  the vast majority of
those who are our computerized users
the classic example imma  we have to
analyze a data set
of a retail point of sale to want to understand
which is the item code with the highest
that achieves the highest
sales volume with greater frequency
within the various geographical areas
where I am.
translates and I am not an
expert but I hope that the eighty percent
of devero persinsala who showed with
great enthusiasm when we saw
the spammer demo may be
familiar to you it says more or less like the
formula you see you see a
a below  imagine if instead of
having to compute it in this way
through the wraps I could ask the
tool how I did before
tell me which article responds to
these characteristics and the tool itself,
interpreting my requests, was
able to translate them into that in that
formula when  'even if it were not necessary to
simply click on a data set
and have proposed from the tool without me
even having to say how to express the
effort  I try to look for data some
statistics that are transformed
into a graphic version
on which I can interact
but it is not only this we said no
we talked about connecting pious people
collaborating and sharing
tools in this sense also
efforts  there are many
the architrave of our plant and a
new google drive the tool where
it first gave us what is needed to connect
people, contents and projects that is
essentially used by our users
to keep up with that complex project
to stimulate that complex process of
stimulating creativity  to collect
possibly exploit ispi to the
contributions of the widest audience of
company collaborators available I am
already 0 now I accelerate badly so
you will hear about it much faster than
that keep in mind this tool
already has 800 million monthly active users
are seen that the eight plus one
google wonder the sla is vist  or
sooner this will probably be the
tenth application that in a
few months will reach the billion
users in google already today it is
used extensively to share
new tools only that we have
decided to switch from a
personal perspective of this tool has a
pin perspective where  the contents and
the activity of a group of people
can be more structured
and in compliance with the dl of the sharing
of information, these can be
traced in some way and that these
remain pertinent to the team so
that if it happens as often happens in the
company that  someone passes from one
project to another
these same remain
in the availability of the team you do not
have to worry about the passage of cards
and anything else we have not even
forgotten the compliance on this
tool we have recently
announced vault for drives and teen drives
which is one  tool that allows me to
manage for example what  retention
the litigation old rather than going
back to the interactions on the files and
guaranteeing their disability we have
not even forgotten to provide you with
tools such as the app bridge to migrate
your
file directors, first of all on the cloud,
as well as integrate through a tool if you wish.
which is called
file streaming within those that
are the director files of mac rather
than windows access to these
contents on
the web we are lucky because on this
slide I have already told you
two very important announcements  as
for the ability to connect
people then one is from this someone
who said a very 2000s tool
the chat very true but also
an essentially familiar and
ergonomic and documented tool of a lot
productivity has become like saying that
extremely familiar hangouts chat
here too it is an attempt to raise an
individual point-to-point perspective to
an integer  tim ration with the creation
of rooms where conversations can be
collected strongly integrated
with what are the
collaboration box tools with the ability to
say to host assets and make the
pertinence of the work of team work
another extremely popular tool
this  is our new
enterprise solution of videoconferencing
rebuilt from scratch the idea is to
want it to become the
communication and connection layer as if to say
within what is the wide
audience of users who go around the
company and therefore  not only between
collaborators belonging to the same
organization but also between
collaborators and customer suppliers who
operate outside the company access
to this city is very simple
you can do it from a calendar from a link
shared by the mobile app from a
telephone bridge in case  the
connection you do not know is not favorable
and hear to access this tool
there is no need to  being on the same
platform no need to have a
client no need to have an
account no need to have a
gmail and no need to
download plug-in software to
access
these are the three  elements that
constitute the architrave of the
collaboration and the effort is that
aimed at eliminating all the complexities
that today have placed a limit
on access to the largest computerized audience
and allow me to say
non-computerized tomorrow to this type
of tools among other things  here I make a
short one very short aside come
later there are two blackout sessions with
two of our partners where we tell
exactly this type of experience
this passage from immanent to
transcendent and how in reality
those transcendent benefits
I mentioned before have materialized
yes  it is talked about however and here we have seen 80
percent are also developers
of integration development tools that
allow development  it seems and expand
what the perimeter the platform
we have added various features in
this sense there are pies that
allow you to integrate individual
applications within
your of your tools
the classic example is that of
an infrastructure  iotti who has a
school of data that I want to collect
on the snatching for example to make it
available rather than to use it
as the integration layer
to do other activities to do other activities
another interesting tool are
addons are built very
powerful platforms and allow access to
information and functionality of your
applications directly from the context
of the e-mail triggering business workflows
based on the context of the
e-mail itself the classic example here is
the integration between the crm e-mail I receive
an e-mail from one of my clients a request
for intervention where the
customer code the intervention code in
the classic case  I would be forced to move
between the two applications
the statistics say that the cost is
about 20 minutes of time with the addons they
can create integrations that
allow you to access the
crm application directly at the required point
based on the context of the
information already on the
page  which allows me to unleash the
workflow that is necessary to carry
out this request
we have not even forgotten to
address the
most pressing needs of addressing apps and
the development of more robust applications
on this platform Turkish and yes
call the app maker I take a moment to
breathe and launch the video
[Music]
the young man in crisis
mons
oh well I hope to have discounted
against your understanding the lack of
modest presumption and the audacity
in having led you on this path
between immanence  and transcendence
I hope you have all realized how the
first test case the first ends
the extraordinary technologies that you have
seen this morning are precisely the
c suite here I stop the
flashing red with great pleasure that
passes the word but the sword director
solutions gp that I beg you to welcome
with a huge applause making him
feel the enthusiasm of milan
and instead google
il nation
i robot software google android
mercedes that armed
new york
[Applause]
miles then as we said we have
many arguments we are going a
bit long so we will try to go
even faster
at this point we start with the customer
panel and I invite alessandra to  go up on
our stage to tell us
what our your experience as
the technologies in barilla thank you very much the
internship all yours thanks to nicola
good morning everyone first of all it is a
pleasure to be here and share
my experience with you calls me alessandra
drizzò is  at work in barilla since 2002
so a lot of time and since the
beginning of 2015 since  when we
started the digital transformation
of our company
I took on the responsibility of the
digital engagement team
today I would like to tell you
first of all a few words about
our group
then I would like to
actually tell you about our experience of
digital transformation the
bari lagos digital program and  finally, of one of
our particular success stories of social
collaboration within the plant
collaboration,
what you see in the slide behind me
is a phrase by pietro barilla that
continually inspires us and that says
give people the food you would like to
give your children
so much so that our corporate mission
is summed up in good for you good for the
planet what it means that it means
that we are oriented towards the search for
good and healthy products but also
sustainable from an environmental impact point of view
as you can see we are about 8,400  people
spread all over the world inside d  the
production plants, mills and offices and
in 2016 we achieved 3.4 million
euros in turnover we are within
the motorcycle
global companies we now move on to the
digital transformation to our
experience what we started
a couple of years ago I would say anti two and a
half years  because the digital transformation
the vortex of digital is actually
swallowing all sectors a bit, even
those who until a few years ago
could have been considered safe in
reality have realized that they are
not at all that they are not immune from
that to this revolution  it is also barilla
that has always produced good
products healthy products could not ignore
what was happening and said
instead of let's say follow the trend
follow the course of events
let's try to anticipate them what you
see is our
vision our goal that is to transform
ours  company in a full digital
enterprise creating value for the
business
precisely because the digit  alizzazione is at the
service of business
the logo and the logo of our
transformation of our
barilla goes digital program and what
we mean by full digital enterprise
we mean a company that makes the
best use of digital technologies as a
competitive advantage
within its internal processes
therefore in the processes and in the dialogue with
external stakeholders how
our digital transformation program is divided
into six transformations 6 streams
very quickly the first who is called
customer shopper into consumer wants to
use technologies on the one hand
to enter into
direct dialogue with
what are the accounts with what the
final consumer thinks for example
through loyalty programs and
on the other hand strengthen what is
the link the relationship with our
stakeholders of reference, that is the
customers the second transformation is
called digital transformation and sees
efficiency through what I
know  no precisely the digital technologies of
our core processes think of chart
finance supply chains and so on
the third haiti governance
transformation is the transformation of our
information technology group which has not been
so called since the beginning of
2015 and which is called digital  business
technology because digital because not
only to support change but
also precisely to trigger it to be a
change agent we had to acquire
new skills and business because in
any case we must be increasingly
business partners of our stakeholders
in business rings terni precisely because
both us and  them with different responsibilities and
skills
we work together for
common objectives
the fourth innovation for
barilla transformation sees the introduction
within our company of
innovative technologies not so much as a mere exercise
of style but with a grounding and
applicability that bring
actually a value  and for our
business
the fifth transformation the
digital people session is the most important
because it sees people at the center precisely
because the digital transformation is not
a technological transformation but
is more about people their way
of working their way of collaborating
together and  finally, the sixth transformation
and enterprise intelligence talks about big
data talks about data that is, we tell ourselves how
we want to use data the large
amount of data we have
available to be able to
direct our business decisions
more and more in  data driven way this
very quickly what is the
whole context of our transformation
during these months we have
learned a few things precisely because we
have faced different challenges
I would like to share with you the three
main lessons of the first that
digital transformation  it is not
simply an efficiency of
the core processes but it is a transformation  and
I will give you an example of the business model we have always made
our core business the
production of sustainable good healthy food
but think about what it means to
enrich the experience of the
final consumer with a whole series of contents
that can be conveyed together with the
product.
for example recipes
nutritional programs think also of physical activity programs
to keep fit
this what it means that the
product remains the central piece of
our business model but in reality
we are going to offer a much
broader service which is that of a  lifestyle
therefore barilla aims to move from
a project
company business model to a business model that is
a lifestyle company the second alessio
lorde to be successful in a
digital transformation
digital technology must not be
seen as an extra within the
organization
but it must go as I told you to change
models of  business must go to
change the value proposition
of the company and the organization that must
become increasingly agile and data driven
the last
the most important the last people
people people and people
because, as I said, digital transformation
is not a transformation
technological but sees success as
a key success factor the
active involvement of people who
must embrace change
and understand its benefits
talking about people what is our
flagship the digital lab the
digital lab was born in mid-2015 and is
a  incubator an incubator where
people can experiment design
experiment new forms of
collaboration and
information sharing of their experience in
agile mode with the aim of
finding new ways of working
simpler more agile different initiatives
have been prototyped by the digital lab and
those of  more successful were taken over
by the company instead of those
a  we felt they did not bring the
expected benefits
we simply left aside
let's say that we have treasured the
experience of experiences baggage
of experiences now I would like to talk to you about the
most successful case of the digital lab
that precisely collaboration collaboration
that is based on an app developed in
partnership with  ingenia sull'hard who
uses g street
precisely because what is collaboration
collaboration new
social collaboration process within the
plant I quickly tell you the genesis
then inside the digital
lab her first steps came to
us
cinzia Bassi l  'then
plant manager of cremona and now manager
of castiglione delle stiviere with
a very strong business nest with a
very strong collaboration precisely
because at that time the
handover on the lines took place through
paper notebooks for which the  operator
on the line had a notebook the
shift supervisor I have another on
maintenance department or another notebook
so you understand that in the end
putting together puzzles was not easy
so much so that every morning at half past eight
the agency with its team
met its front line to take stock
of the
perfect situation a first attempt to
digitize and make social this
collaboration process was
made by the maintenance team
using whatsapp and already there the
first benefits were glimpsed so the
vicenza request was helped us to
actually make
this this new one a little more structured  social
collaboration and of course we
could only be happy with the
request because we understood the
business value behind it so
what we did
we started from two
production lines in Cremona we developed
an app very very very raf very
let's say embryonic and  we gave it to
people's hands we put tablets
on the lines of p  production and we
gave smartphones to the maintainers
so at this point what happened that the
people on the operators on the line
could photograph making videos post
20 and make them available throughout the
whole community in practice for
which there was a sharing 1 sharing
of the information of what happened that
has never been seen before
and all were producers of that
knowledge
what you see behind me is
a screenshot of what is our
app you see the interaction an example of
social interaction for which we are
responsible for  production that posts
a request the maintainer that the
perfect apex I take it in charge I will
do it tomorrow
actually then closes the post
saying very well I the intervention
performed and you understand the power
of this interaction because everyone
can see everything for  which you understand well
that there is an alignment and a
capitalization of knowledge never
seen before p  rima collaboration
started quietly but brought
very very important outcomes first of
all he made the information
available to everyone
I repeat realtime in an unambiguous way
because he understood well that a photo
rather than a video speaks much
better than a written text
increased effectiveness and
speed of taking charge of any
non-conformities favored the
capitalization of know-how the setting
of best practices and also the
team spirit because social collaboration
quickly strengthened the team from the
two production lines
from which we are  we started we scale we
climbed to the whole plant but not only in
a few months
the solution was adopted by all 6
becker italy plants
you see with more than a thousand people who
use our app to date
our the new process
the numbers  by the end of 2018 they are these
or we are planning to
spread to scale the application on
1  8 plant italy and abroad bakery and pasta
mil involving about 2,700 people
you see that the numbers are
truly incredible numbers and I would like to
close my story with a quote that
in my opinion is right for us and that says
that social media have actually
brought and are bringing  but by now we
are already at the democratization of
information and therefore of
knowledge that therefore there is not only
more patrimony than everyone but is created and
produced by the whole community that
puts experience in common and that
also leads to the capitalization of
knowledge  language that has become
conversational many to many for which
collaboration is an excellent example of
how social collaboration brings
value to business and thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much alessandra is really
congratulations for sharing this
project first of all for having
thought about it and then thank you for having it
shared with all of us now the panel
continues with another client an
halt  ro very important customer so
call on the maximum stage to
tell their experience with our
technology in sky
thanks a lot to the hour
good morning everyone thanks to google for
inviting me here in particular
because I grew up in via tortona
so I'm very at home  I
will probably tell you I make a
presentation a bit particular in the
sense first of all sky tyler sepede who it
is for which it is useless to tell you who
we
are we are a television for which first of all
a media company for which however I have not
brought videos so it does not pester you rho
with videos we have started
independently now the number of
subscribers and what we do we have
obviously started a few years ago to
extend our presence to be
let's say omni present where possible
with our contents for our customers
obviously trying to serve in the
best way in the shortest time  right also
with technology because
we are typically recognized at sky  even with a
very innovative company in our field, however, it
is an innovation that we do very
under control or we do not deliver many things
even when they are ready badly we
deliver only when our
customer is ready to receive them to the extent
not of the individual customer but when
the  The largest possible group of customers
is ready to receive the relationship with
google when it is
born apart from the various relationships that we can
have with google but in this
specific project when it is born
when the company has asked us a place
a normal technological question of
evolution  of the offer on our
customers and he told us well we are a
platform that we also offer content
once instead of making a hundred in fact a
thousand now without going to tell the
details
then I have to be honest I'm not
working everyone told when they
work time and  I have been working on television for 25
years in the media world and so let's
say I know a lot about it here and I am  from a
story that I am certainly not a
digital native
I created digital but I am not a
digital native and when
obviously this question arose one of the themes since
we were talking about an
ecosystem that we had already virtualized
was okay  we use the cloud obviously
when sky says let's use the cloud
almost everyone who offered
cloud arrived and even my collaborators
insisted on his claudos and I have
always been very suspicious I
have to be honest I'm sorry to say it not
yet not  the real benefit is very clear
now I say then the real
benefit is obviously there if I would not be
here but conceptually the theme was
because many are presented with a
prize and therefore he would tell me what I
care about having something placed 50 km
from my house  that it was so much anyway
I already knew what I needed if I
already had how many things I needed
actually saying then chatting obviously
there are a thousand  after we see what are a
thousand thousand advantages because we
chose then first of all because we
arrived at why I am hesitant about the
cloud as regards
our specificity because
because the theme was for us and transferring
large amounts of data
data that cannot be broken up
are  of the large fi data that must
be transferred to maintain and
the entirety of the quality everything that
is television in the strict sense
of television via the part of
the video component where, net of everything,
for us the qualitative theme is who
is pivotal because  what determines the
value for money we have compared to
other platforms
so finding a compromise on this
was for the company
for me the wine was also
quite impossible for us to
move very large files and to do so
typically it is better to have them at home
because  or have big pipes to
be able to transmit them when we have been
told oh well let's use  or the cloud which
we plan to use but how can you
transfer that amount of data how much it
costs me then after the game is how much it costs
the crowd costs little but it costs me so much to
take the car to get
to the cloud then let's say what was the
moment in which we said oh well
let's go to the cloud because we have found
an intermediate solution in which without
losing quality we have succeeded we have
found a way to transport this
amount of content guaranteeing we are
the qualitative entirety in a not
so heavy way then you have here was the
moment why we chose google now
I have to say honestly I felt with
great pleasure the excellent interventions of
this morning
I do not know if all the more beautiful more
surely we have found
very intelligent people this I have to be
honest we have found other personalities
of people smart people who have more  of
others they got in tune with us this
we say completely lowered the
barriers  that we had that I had in the first place
towards this type of approach
obviously combined with a
technological solution that could support
us that we said well then through a
replay that was also named who
was our let's say integrator
supported us in this type of
experience
we started this
adventure we obviously started it on this one
here then I quote and then the
final architecture but I saw the minutes Italy
we got there in two in two we
got there
slowly we all
worked to have a peering that
could guarantee us  the throughput
necessary to move even if
those that are very bulky files have been reduced
the second thing
was to use a system of
taking ball of the virtual machines
such that it allowed us to use
everything that the
why the  cloud is a core could
offer us that is a scalability when
we had  need because we
need
it actually one could say well
you still have the ability to study
schedules also have a certain type of
programming for which there would in theory be no
need to actually as you
know people die so the actors
when they die you have to transmit
all movies have all the movies available
in instant time to celebrate
someone's death or during
big events there are big there is a
mobilization of large amounts of
content that must be managed
this has led us to a
very flexible solution that  obviously we don't
see the moment ending here for us
at the moment we are working with
virtual machines obviously before we were
talking about containers for us
the next step is to expand
this type of relationship go with a
technology based on container and
above all start not only to  doing
this type of business
but also expanding it for
valuable services  a little more strategic which does
not mean that these are not, however,
some more delicate contents such
as live events that could be
thanks to some precautions made
could also be brought into
use directly from the cloud
the theme is because why we have
arrived at  do this because, as I told you,
the world of the media and those who do
as the colleague previously said,
that is, it is inevitable that
in order to run after the various needs, it is
necessary to flexibilize
one's processes as much as possible one's activities to
be essentially ready for anything with
without having the  let's face it the compromise
of lowering the quality towards
the end users
then in this mix of
transformation list that sees us
involved the cloud represented was
represented for this project is
representing for a series of projects
that we are analyzing for the next
year a bit
the pivotal point to then be able to
off  to do what we want to do in
the simplest way and the alchemy of costs
obviously important to this
cannot be done
in this economic situation and it is not
possible to do without talking about it
and it is clear that it is a basic component I
would have closed with this I hope to  has not
moved even in the times and thank you
very much for your attention
thanks really maximum convincing the
skeptics is part of our job to
hear us give even the smart ones
really fills us with pride at
this point we continue with the last
panel I call on the Easter stage for indeed
he will tell us why if he is alone
to tell about your experience
with our cloud technologies thanks me
thank you very much hello everyone as
you can see I am alone and I offer you an
apology from alberto ricchiari who was
unable to arrive in time for
the presentation remains common anyway
with us
smiling in this photo but we can
go on then I will tell you and I have the
pleasure of rac  count you rick lazio google
for this opportunity
one of the many initiatives we have
launched within the Cattolica group as
part of a path of
innovation and digital transformation
now launched a few years ago and which
sees us collaborating with google
in the use of solutions that
they concern both the g suite and the google
cloud platform
the initiative I am presenting to you is in my
opinion an interesting but
also very ambitious initiative, it undoubtedly sets itself an
economic goal we
have focused on a component that
heavily affects the budget of an
insurance company  that the course
of the accident is the sums that the
company must settle pay to
its insured to reimburse the
damage
also the vehicle suffers in the event of an
accident
in the event of a road accident we
therefore concentrated on the estimation process,
i.e. how the damage is determined  which
the vehicle traditionally undergoes
this appraisal process is entrusted to
fiduciary specialists of the company
of technical experts who go to the
customer to view the vehicle
take photos and then
determine an estimate of the damage which is then
substantially communicated to the
company.We wondered if
the time was ripe to
imagine and think that a computer  a
machine could be substituted for a
human being and therefore for a specialist
therefore with technical skills that are also
quite strong in
making this damage estimate,
starting simply from
the analysis of the photos we looked around
thanks also to the collaboration of
some particular partners  noodle
and we have identified within the
google cloud platform some objects
some components that were particularly suited to
our
case the google viewed which
helped us to interpret the
content of the photos and the google cloud
machine link engine based on the powerful
meaning engine
now unfortunately for  matters  of time I do not
go into the detail of the algorithms
used to implement the
inference model and of planning in reality not
being able but I recommend instead
how the project has developed
starting from an assumption
that the result we have set ourselves to
achieve is a result  certainly
aleatory therefore certainly not
starting from this belief therefore we
preferred not to start a
traditional project is based on the classic
phases of analysis development test and then
release into production but we have
set up a real experimental laboratory
in which computer experts but
also process experts participate  therefore aspects
of the process of determining the
expertise and the estimate that are
collaborating in a mode already in we
therefore set ourselves immediate objectives
precisely to feel the
potential of the tools we had
at our disposal
first objective was to see if
machine learning is able to
ide  ntificate via google viewed
the license plate inside a photo of a
vehicle in very few weeks
we were able to properly instruct
the machine to obtain
considerable results therefore a
very high percentage of successful recognition suicides certain of the license plate
we then tried  to see if we were
able to recognize
the presence of the same vehicle on different photos even
if it is taken from different perspectives
we then calculated a
distance index that more or less measures the degree
of similarity and we also tried to
artificially modify the photos
by changing the license plate  changing the vehicle
, however, obtaining the confirmation that the two
vehicles were identical,
therefore starting from these two
tactical objectives we asked ourselves a certain point
but why we do not use them within the
company and therefore we
transformed into which queen which
then went to enrich  the tools that
compag  nia available to
check the network of trustees and b
to intercept
potentially fraudulent situations
we concentrated therefore studies the
main objective the
main objective therefore that of being able
to automatically determine the estimate of the
damage
starting from the analysis of the photo we
divided the process into two  main phases
in a first main phase we have
introduced a model capable of
recognizing
some factors within the photo
that we call predictors
predictive factors that then serve to
better characterize the damage that
I repeat in the photo
these positive factors
such as the damaged part
or the extent of the damage, therefore, if
mild, medium, severe and many others that
obviously I will never be able to detect
even under torture have led to
the damage being clustered in an appropriate manner,
thus making it
substantially identifiable for
certain characteristics
this clustering was then
reimm  it in a new machine
learning model that starting from the history of the
appraisals that have been carried out over
time by Cattolica Assicurazioni
was able to identify an average of the
estimate of the damage obviously equal to the
cluster of the damage itself what we are
doing and what we would like to do  in the
coming times now first of all we would like to
use the amount of information
that is present in the so-called
black boxes as imputed to the model
obviously the greater the app the
sterilization therefore the more refined the
clustering the greater the
depth history of the appraisal the more
certain it is more certain and obviously the estimate
secondly, we are thinking of
reviewing the complaint process by
entrusting the customer with the task
of taking the photos through the Cattolica app
and then detecting the damage
these photos then taken are
acquired will be
automatically acquired by the google cloud
platform which  processing them will obviously be able
to  you, under certain conditions, propose
the amount to be refunded directly on the Cattolica client app, then the
sum proposed for payment
in the event that the customer should
accept at that point the claim
closes I
conclude with a wish and a wish is
to  see more and more in reality
historically anchored in tradition as
financial institutions can be
see projects that we said are no longer
traditional but more and more experimental
the important thing is, however, that there is the
awareness that this type of
project does not always lead to the
achievement of a result
.  so with the right spirit
I like to mention this in nelson
mandela when he says I do not lose but
I win or in part
thank you very
much and congratulations and capture
that insurance thank you very much to pascale
for doing double work in managing
this presentation then as
we said we are  winding down
I still feel a lot of energy in the room
and therefore I am a lot  happy I hope that
the topics we have covered have
been of interest to you
I will make a very quick re.cup of what
we have seen we have clearly seen
how to work safely
how to work
intelligently how to collaborate in
a different way within
companies such as  build platforms
that are more open and flexible
now the day of the
morning program comes to an end
then we will have three
parallel breakouts where we will go to
technically deepen a whole series of
solutions
I obviously remind you to follow
these breakouts you have the program with
you I think
no not  he was here and I also remind you that
towards the end of the day at this
point around 6.30
there will probably also be a part
dedicated to our partners a
specific breakout where they will present case
studies of some of their customers I with
this thank you I hope  that it was
an interesting day  I wish you a
good continuation see you soon
[Applause]